I want to move that one to that Rod
Holder there to.
Might as well just have it there.
Well we’re down here in Chatham.
We've got a bunch of boats with us.
We have T.J.
from hot tuna.
We got Jack on time flies Paul on Wicked Pissah.
So there's a bunch of us down here.
Hopefully we can all work together
and find the life.
We're very thankful.
There's a lot of boats to work with.
The key to catching fish in
Chatham is sharing information.
So the more boats,
the more eyes on the water, the better.
I've got about six or seven
fish on the screen right now,
200 up to 150.
Oh mama.
Are you traveling
or are you fishing are you fishin?
We’re fishing.
Are you right where you said there ah
Seven, 11, eight, 15.
I'll head down that way.
Right now we've got a big wolf pack stacked up
on the bottom, some 200 up to 150
marking sand eels
So we'll see what happens here.
Bubby just let Bob know
what we're seeing here.
So hopefully we can both get them.
That's the best case scenario.
We're ready for battle
Lets set one up here.
All right.
I’m ready when you are.
I'm on the on the spot here
already marking.
we're just deploying our first
two baits, so we're hoping to get a nice
quick bite here, but we'll see.
Hopefully it works out for both of us
today.
Oh, look at this.
Oh, my God.
Yep, yep, yep.
Yeah.
We’re on!
Fat Tuna hooked up.
Go get him bud!.
Right, right, right.
Started.
It's crazy. Yep.
Here we go again.
First bait out less than 20 minutes.
Little bit of a weird bite here.
It’s either gut hooke again
or a short.
We're definitely hooked up to a tuna.
Its acting kind of funny.
Doesn't want to take any big runs.
Isn't taking a lot of drag.
So we'll play it out here
and see what happens.
Another gut hooked fish.
Jump on him Johnny.
Marking right there.
as it is down in Chatham.
A lot of times they grab this bait
off the bottom and they bring it up.
And while they're doing that,
they're not tight.
So they gut hook it.
So he's another gut hooked fish
just like the other day.
The biggest thing you worry about
when it got gut hooked fish is the line chafing
because the hook is all the way down
the fish's throat.
Every time it moves it, sharp
teeth are rubbing against the line.
So we need to do whatever we can
to get this fish in quickly
before the line snaps. Swivel.
Here, let me hop in
at this point.
Go for it
big guy.
Yeah. Yeah.
Coming in hot.
He's going to circle around here.
Come on.
Right there.
Right, right there.
Nice shot, buddy,
he looked like a good one.
He's a real good one Bub a real good one.
What? Why? What's what?
It's not in him,
what the ****
harpoon stopped.
Just brought it back
The tip is still on the pole.
We thought we hit that fish.
We didn't hit that fish. Pissed him off.
Yeah.
I tell you what, it almost looks like
we hit a hard spot on that fish.
Probably a gill plate.
Thought for sure that thing was in them.
Never celebrate too early.
He's a bit gassed.
You're going to get another shot here.
you got him
No, it's not.
No, it's not. Get the gaff.
Get the other.
The other harpoon hit him again
hit him again hit him again.
He’s gassed.
Hit him again
wrapped up
first bait.
20 minutes on the fish.
That's why we come down here.
Got him.
Good job Bob.
Very good.
Pretty work on the fish, Bob.
Nice work, Bubba.
Just kind of landed on him
with the help from you guys.
Thank you.
All right,
let's get a measurement on this thing.
92, baby.
Yeah, we’ll take that. Nice.
Every trip it’s why we come down here.
That's why we come down here
working together.
That's what it's all about.